hello and welcome it's March 13th 2024
and we're here in active inference guest
stream number
75.1 active inference with empathy
mechanism for socially behaved
artificial agent in diverse situations
with t Yuki matsumura kanako isaki and
huki Mizuno so thank you all for joining
and looking forward to hearing your talk
and
discussion okay thank you for inviting
us to such a good opportunity and I'm T
and my co researcher kanako and huki
also join this
discussion we are developing AI
especially AI which is inspired by
humanik autonomous agent to make social
artificial agent recently we published a
paper related to the idea in Journal of
a life the title is active imp with
empathy mechanism for socially behaved
artificial agent in diverse
situations first I'd like to explain the
paper this is the motivation of This
research at the title of the paper shows
the motivation of This research is to
develop socially behaved artificial
agent we believed that sociality will
become an important point to apply AI in
our daily
life the difficulty to realize social
agent is that an appropriate social
behavior depend on a given situation or
culture as described in the bottom
figure we have sociality even in just
working case for example how fast should
we walk or how much distance from others
orah blah blah so if we Implement
sociality with rule based program we
have to design a lot of magic number for
each
situations this is
impossible because there are a white
variety of
situations due to this unified mechanism
or principle for social behavior is
required this is the
challenge we assume that we humans has
such unified behavior model because we
humans can behave socially in diverse
situations and we develop social Eng
inspired by human behavior model namely
three principle three energy principle
and active
inflence in this research we use the
active inflence for the basis of the
behavior model of human life agent as
you know active inference is a concept
proposed in the free energy principle
and free energy principle is a unified
hypo for our variety of cognitive
activities in the FP our cognitive
activities are explained by such that
first we have internal models for
predicting future of surrounding
environment and second we always try to
minimize the free energy of the model
free energy is defined by this equation
and it
intuitively represent uncertainty of
prediction the interesting point of the
FP is that the internal model if not
only the hidden state but also actions
for the agent that is the action to be
taken is the action which minimize the
free energy of the agent this is the
basic idea of active inference as I
understand
it intentional actions also can be
explained in the active inference in
this case we consider expected free
energy which is the free energy for the
future State when considering much time
Step Ahead expected energy at much time
Step Ahead is considered as described in
the right
figure based on the expected free energy
for each action the distribution the
action is determined such that the
smaller the expected free energy the
higher the probability of
section when we consider intentional
Behavior intentions are considered as
PRS of future observations and reward
according to the Future observation are
encoded into the first time into the uh
in the last
equation these are my understanding of
the standard active inference and the
behavior model of the humanik agent
based on
it we extend this active inference to
generate the social behavior the idea of
the extension is explained using a
situation in which there are two agents
called I and other the agent called I is
the subject of the action in this
explanation
the biological agent under the AC
inference makes predictions about the
environment and take some action to
minimize the uncertainty of the
prediction in this figure I predict
future beh I predict future behavior of
the other because the a is an
environment for I namely I act to reduce
uncertainty for the for the other so far
this is a standard active
inference here if we consider that the
other is also a biological agent we can
assume that the other also act under the
active inference under this idea we can
assume that the other also predict the
future of behavior of me and the other
tr to is the uncertainty of the
prediction about me in this
session in this understanding we notice
that our action can reduce not only our
own free energy but also that of the
other this is because my action affects
not only my own free energy but also the
free energy of the others if
I can predict others prediction for me I
can act to I can act to release the free
energy of the other this is the idea of
the proposed extension of the active
inference we extend FP and active
inference from an individual idea to an
Collective idea as described in this
image of concept the agent imaginary
share the brain and they try to minimize
the free energy of the shared
brain to relas the free energy for the
shared brain we act not only for me but
also for the others because of this
action for others we expect that this
idea can be used to generate social
behavior which is a behavior for us not
only only for me or only for
you to realize this idea it is necessary
to predict others prediction about
myself this is implemented based on the
mirror system and simulation Theory
hypothesis for the mechanism of
empathy in this in the miror system and
simulation Theory it is that that we
understand others by simulating others
by own
bodies we consider the idea of using our
own body to simulate others as using our
internal model to infer other
prediction the overview of the mechanism
is described in the
figure the agent has the internal model
to predict future observation for his
own observation moreover we use the same
internal model to predict others
prediction about myself Al the model is
the same the input to the model is
changed to the observation of the others
for this the process of inference of
others observation is
included for example when the observ is
an image Noel view synthesis which is
the problem of generating images from
different Viewpoint can be used in this
in the other case as we will discuss in
the following evaluation if the
observation is the location of the agent
for ordinate transformation
transformation can be used based on this
inference procedures the expected free
energy is is expended as described in
this
equation as with the encoding of
intentional Behavior we add a time to
the first time that is intentional to
respond to the expect expectation of
others if there are multiple others the
some of each other expectation is
considered we call the proposed idea
empathic activ
we evaluate the proposed idea using the
control task of an autonomous autonomous
mobile agent in the evaluation multiple
agent move to each Target point the
shortest path of each agent intersect
each other and agent are required to
take cision avoidance behavior the
prayer this red agent is controlled by
the proposed method and the other agent
are controlled by the social force model
social force model is a simple social
working model roughly set it is a
Dynamics model in which the walking
speed and direction are determined by
two
forces the first one is driving force to
the go and the second is repulsive force
from the others in this evaluation the
weight of the weight the weight of these
two type of forces are changed to
evaluate different situations where are
two type of others selfish or aristic
others when the for to the goal is
larger than the force from others the
agent take behavior in selfish on the
other hand the force for the from the
others is larger than the PO to the go
the agent take behavior in
alistic this a example of the behavior
of others under the control of the
social force model the player let CLE
randomly moved and the others green blue
or orange moved with social force model
the top picture is an example for
selfish others and the bottom picture is
an example for an aristic
a the difference is from the difference
of the magnitude of the two forces as
you can see from the figures when other
are characteristic the other will take
the p with uh P which has more margin
with others
the setup for the prayer is simply disre
described the action space is defined in
discrete space movement for five
directions and weight weight current
position totally six action is assumed a
simple variational o encod like model is
used to the internal model and the model
is with the offline man the model is
used to predict the expected free energy
for each
action first the evaluation result when
there is only one other besides the
prayer as shown we discussed the poity
of the agent based on the for view point
the first one if my travel my travel
distance is longer it is social behavior
and the second if the other travel
distance is shorter it is social
behavior the start if the minimum margin
among agent is larger it is social
behavior
for if the inequality of the travel
distance is smaller it is social
behavior inquality means that the
difference in Trav distance among agents
as a comparison we also show the result
of the standard active inference
cases the two figures in the left side
are the case when the others are selfish
in this case the prayer with the
standard active inference moves straight
to the destination because the prayer
Act optimally only for its own purpose
on the other hand the proposed agent to
Appo the others as well as as well as
the other because the prayer predict
that the other expect to the prayer to
avoid collision and the prayer try to
respond to it as a result of taking this
the two P the sociality of the behavior
is increased namely the travel distance
of the prayer increased compared to the
that of the standard active inference
case at the same time the travel
distance of the others decrease and the
minimum distance between the prayer and
the other increase in addition the
inequality of the difference in travel
distance is
decreased next the case where other
aristic is shown on the light two
figures in this case the same tendency
is observed as in the case where of
others other is selfish but the player
moved a pass with larger margin to the
other to the other compared to the case
of selfish
other the result indicates that the
proposed agent can behave in Social
manner that
is that benefical to the other even if
the result are disadvantageous to
itself an important point is that the
difference of the social behavior does
not depend on any reward designing as in
reinforcement running namely the
sociality depend on the character of the
other around the
prayer the other around the prayer is
not just obstacle for the agent but uh
as a a teacher for the social
[Music]
manner
s in the case where three others besides
the prayer are similar
result observe in the aristic as a case
namely the travel distance of the prayer
is increased and that of others are
decreased and the minimum margin is
increased and inquality of the travel
distance is decreased on the other hand
in the case of selfish others a
collision occurred it may be due to high
density in the center point in this case
the proposed agent can avoid collision
by waiting the crossing of
others I repeat the important point
there is no need to design leward or
penalty for
sociality in each
situation a social behavior realized by
respon responding to the other
expectation finally I would like to
summarize the explanation of the paper
as I said at the first SL the motivation
of This research is to develop unified
mechanism for social
behavior the answer for the motivation
is that learning an internal model to
predict the future behavior of others
this is same as standard free energy
principle or inference more more over
predict others expectation about me with
the same internal model and try to
respond to the others
expectation this this process make a
cyclic process and it encourage the
agent to behave like surrounding others
because due to mirror system other
expectation to me are same same to my
expectation to others this mechanism
encourages agent to behave like
surounding
others this summary shows our idea for
what is social behavior the answer is
that social behavior is a behavior like
surrounding others the others are not
obstacle but teacher for social behavior
this also mean that we are teacher of AI
or robot for the future
Society that's so this is the
explanation of the
paper i' like to discuss about
it
thank
you would either of the other authors
like to say hello or to give any
remarks hello I
amaki also a researcher at and
um um I I have been studying on the
control of system especially system with
hardware and uh my recent interest is
how to apply the
after robot
system hello my name is H I'm
responsible for This research thank you
for giving us this wonderful
time thank
you okay many interesting um questions
but definitely very striking
results about the tolerance to a variety
of different social settings for the
active inference
algorithm
to by nature of always updating at each
time step based upon the
expectations able to kind of deal with a
range of different settings like
different numbers of Agents
and the different um Behavior types for
the
agents um I'll I'll ask some questions
that were submitted by hear you Sam
no no or okay now
okay
all good all good okay I will read some
questions that were submitted by email
by shohi wakayama and also we'll look to
the live chat so I'll start with the
fourth question he wrote I would like to
receive more detailed explanations of no
operation action the noop in general
because I noticed also in the graphics
that when there's going to be a
collision that the active inference
agent just stops so how did you model or
calibrate that decision to make a move
at all versus which way to move
forward
okay first I'd like to answer what is
the no operation a
NOP I mean no is just a no
operation
so
in the evaluation case not means wait
the current
po the agent take no movement action the
agent stay the current position this is
a not operation no
operation and the question is very
important
because this is a critical problem to
realize our
method the problem is that we want to
decide an action but the procedure we
proposed requires to decide
action as described in this figure the
let Circle action actions for others we
decide to action of
the agent but it requires the deciding
other action this
cyclic requirement is very difficult
problem so we have to set some option
for the
others the S
I think there is there are solution
straty three solution strategies the
first one is assume random action
apprising the result of the randomly
selected actions the second is predict
predict action learning and predict
using policy Network for example Alpha
go use this
strategy and the last one is we selected
the thir strategy is that assume
specific action no operation means I
don't
take any actions and you act as a
priority
please I
mean
NOP I mean this idea you for
assuming
no so I believe that humans has such
sociality in
natur this is the reason
why I use the sad
idea
does it make sense yes okay next um
question how do you tune or calibrate
the model so that it's in an in an area
of State space that's
pro-social like maybe you could have a
generative model that just only did nope
and it was just paralyzed or another one
just goes straightforward and no matter
what so how how do you explore that
state space and choose which parameters
are open for updating and which
parameters are going to be like explored
during the design phase and then fixed
at
runtime oh at runtime
uh I don't adjust any parameter at long
time the model is Tred and offline
Manner and the parameter model
is explore explore searched at the
training
phas but
the parameter space is not so huge in
this case because the model is very
simple the observation is just a two
dimensional information X and
Y that means location of the agent
so in the case of four agent there is
just
eight
eight dimensional space but we need
sometime
steps
so
but even that case the dimension is not
so large so the hidden state is also not
so
lar can you
understand yes evaluation situation is
very simple so the model is also simple
so I don't
search parameter with a rot of IND
[Music]
that is not
PA simply just to try to some parameter
and I pick up a best parameter
set so this was a this was an in
silico software only simulation right oh
yes this is just the simulation about
simulation so um how did you tune it and
then I guess a bigger question and
definitely one that a lot of people are
interested in in learning active
inference is like how do you go from
having a in silico
simulation to bringing that onto a
physical
robot like what are the steps in the
process between having the
situation in the simulation and bringing
it into like a
room yes that's a very interesting point
and it's very important and Han try
to app the active inference into the
real robot so how about do you think
kind
um so
uh so I I I I I also tried in a small uh
space for to apply the this after to the
robot so um I have just an idea that um
um maybe uh The Continuous space is the
important um key for to uh PRS
simulation to the physical
world
and in general uh the problem is also
the problem in reinforcement running I
think so the techniques in reinforcement
running field also can be applied into
the active inference cases for example
simulation to simulation to real I I
don't remember the name of technique
but s
maybe such techniques can be applied in
the case of active
inference but I don't know there is a
activ inference specific
technique I don't know such
Tech that's interesting about the
continuous State spaces because in the
discrete State space where you have the
marov decision process you get the big
planning trees but our experience like
walking through a crowd or maybe waiting
at a intersection it's not necessarily
based upon planning it's a lot more on
the path and the curvature of the path
that's planned and maybe the paths that
others are expected to take as they move
through space to
so that's possibly like a simpler
representation yes that could give
natural movement Behavior with a just a
few
[Music]
parameters thank you and there is a
another problem for applying this
technique to a real world that is a
computational cost because we use the
monard simulation to start the best
option I think this is not sweet to to
the real situation so if we try to apply
this technique to the real application
we have to solve the computational cost
problems I think
so yeah another part even outside of the
decision making
computational costs would be like going
from the video camera data oh yes when
you're getting the exact location data
perfectly you're in the minimum you're
like kind of playing chess in the state
Space versus to have noisy sensors there
might need to be a lot of um uh
observation model here a lot of
layers before the simple kind of active
INF could even
happen okay I'll ask another question
from uh shohi so question five he wrote
in this study the behaviors of the
standard active inference agent and the
empathetic agent are compared I would
like to know why you did not compare the
proposed method with other game
theoretic approaches because the metrics
like travel distance can be appli
appable to these methods as
well
oh the reason
why I compare the proposed method with
active inference is that the aim of the
paper is to extend the active inference
to the social social behavior manner so
it is not I think it is natural to
compare the proposed me
standard activ
forance but the question is
that why we don't compare the proposed
method with the other games theoric
method I don't I'm not sure what this
means the games theoric method but if
the that mean the reinforcement running
method
the reason why I don't compare it is
that just it need a lot of time to
compare it
and
I I think it is important but the main
focus of this paper is to evaluate
the
quantitative future of the propos method
and the
qualitative varation
is not so
important for us at the
moment but I think it is important and I
have to compare it in future
work so there is
no real reason this is just
uh we don't have uh much time to compare
it thank you makes
sense um another question so the
movement was
being influenced by the relative ratio
of the F other and F
goal yes
so here F other is kind of like a um
electrostatic
repulsion from other
agents how does it how does it come into
play that the red agent is entertaining
beliefs about what other agents
think
sorry can you repeat the question yeah
so here the two forces acting on the red
agent are the the gravity for the goal
and the repulsion for the proximity of
other
agents yes
so where or how does it come into to
play that the agent is
actually thinking what other agents are
going to
do like the birds flocking
simulations that have the simple rules
like go in the same direction as the
other birds and maintain a distance
between them but that doesn't require a
theory of mind for the other
birds
Oh you mean how the agent know the H
from the others
or ah you mean how the agent know the
course of goal of
others yeah it's just running away from
others or is it actually imagining what
they
think
so uh that's good question yes
uh in this
simulation
uh
s the answer is that the
destination destination the others
uh
given I don't remember the detail of the
evaluation I
think
but a
Sor the agent don't have to know the
information at first I think I give the
information to the agent but
that
information does not
need the
[Music]
asan
yeah
so the goals of the others are not not
expressely given but uh the with
internal model uh the agent can
predict um the
path test so we can
pred uh go like go but uh not not
exped does it exp does the red agent
explicitly model what the others are
going to
do or it just has heris stics that it
follows when they
move the foral one so only predict
the action recent action
and yes near
future yes the agent just learn the
future position of the others this is
the all of
the task of the internal model
so there's no need to give the go of the
others yes I think this is very
interesting aspect like to what extent
the social behavior rests upon Simple
Rules like
etiquette like passing on the right or
on the left that don't
require knowledge about the internal
states of others or even what kind of
thing they are whereas the experience of
sociality and a lot of the psychology of
Sociology focuses on very cognitive
mechanisms that are
very
expressive
thank
you this is because the action is
repeated to decided in short time
duration
so this
is uh future of the proposed method as
you
said thank you I don't notice that that
is
important
um
where are you going to go in your
continuing research or development
directions
sorry future
[Music]
please
uh I
think uh an important point is the
regulating the
empathy and we have a presentation the
last year uh conference about artificial
life in the
presentation we
discussed how regulates the emotion our
empathy this mean that we to uh the
paper we in is that the expected the pre
energy is extended to the including
others so D called D my plus the others
and the there is there should be weight
of empathy that means
uh
W in this equation we have to regulate
this
parameter I
don't consider the parameter in the
Journal paper but we have to
regulate this parameter because
there's diverse others there's good
person or there's part person we should
not empathy to the part address so this
is the important point I'll emphasize
others and
we tackle this problem with the emotion
emo we tled this problem with
the regard to the
emotional
context okay this is a a future work and
we publish uh we have a presentation at
the at the current conference
so if you have some interesting please
read this
paper that's very
interesting like in a lot of the active
inference and social sciences
conversations that we've had here
there's a lot of discussion about like
how do you
balance the the coefficients in the free
energy calculations for self and
others yes because you're making
decisions at a very short time scale
like speech and second by second but
then sociality is very
longterm and so you could make a
decision that
is um aligned locally but then very out
of alignment at a longer time scale
especially if these other four have
complex relation
relationships then action is not very
simple
Yes is there any other um things that
the other authors want to say or
anything else you want to talk
about
I I don't
[Music]
have cool well thank you very much for
joining the
discussion thank you thank
you yes good luck with the ongoing work
and I hope to stay in touch and hear
more about the research in the
future thank very
much
okay thank you see you
later
bye
fine
for